-This has been
a fantastic year for you.
"Logan" was, for my money,
one of the great
superhero movies of all time.
You and Hugh Jackman.
And he said it was
his last time playing Wolverine,
and then you announced
that it would be your last time
playing Professor Xavier.
-Yeah.
It was unexpected.
I did not plan that,
but we were at,
what was for me,
my first public screening
at the Berlin Film Festival.
I was sitting alongside Hugh,
and the last five
or six minutes of the movie
are quite emotional.
-Very much so.
-And sad.
And at one point, Hugh just
reached over and took my hand
and squeezed it like this.
And I thought, when the movie
ended and the credits rolled --
We had to sit and wait there
for a long time
as the credits rolled.
I realized there can be
no better way,
no more appropriate way
to say farewell
to the X-Men franchise
than the scenes I've just seen.
And so, the next morning,
I made the announcement
at the press conference
that I was done, too.
-Well, that's wonderful.
It is --
You are right.
It is the perfect exit
for the --
-Nevertheless,
the franchise will go on
without me and Hugh Jackman.
-Yeah.
Well, there's
the wonderful James McAvoy,
who plays young Xavier.
-[ Scoffs ] Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Mm. Okay.
You don't --
You don't seem to hold him
in the same esteem that I do.
-I have enormous respect
for James McAvoy.
He's a brilliant actor.
-He played --
He was the young poop emoji
in that clip, as well, right?
-Yeah, that's right!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Only, in his case,
that was perfect casting.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-When -- When he --
When it was announced
that he was gonna play
the young Charles Xavier, he was
on a red carpet somewhere,
and he said,
"So, tell me, how does --
How does it feel
to be going into the shoes,
albeit the younger shoes,
of Patrick Stewart?"
And James said, "I'll bury him."
[ Laughter ]
Good man, yes.
I'd vote for that.
He's outstanding.
And they're already --
I was shooting in Montreal
the last few -- five weeks,
and the next "X-Men" movie
is in the works.
-Yeah, it's very exciting.
Now, I will say, one of
the things about "Logan" --
not a film for children.
It was a very violent --
It was R-rated.
You got to curse a bit,
which must have been fun
for Professor X.
-Well, it was all a part of
the loosening of Charles' mind,
Charles, who was
a significant intellectual
in every aspect of his life.
Brilliant thinker,
brilliant analyst,
has had so much disturbance
in his life.
But one of the things
that has collapsed
is his brilliant language.
So now he uses coarse,
abusive words.
-It was great to watch.
But, of course,
then children can't watch.
You have four grandchildren,
and --
-Nope, they haven't seen it.
-They haven't seen it.
-No.
-But are they excited about
the "Emoji" film?
[ Light laughter ]
They are.
And are they excited --
Let me follow up.
Are they excited --
Do they know your casting,
and are they excited about that?
-They do, because someone
told my grandson, Sebastian,
at school.
"Did you know?
Did you know?
Your granddad's
gonna be playing poop!"
[ Laughter ]
And my daughter-in-law
called me and said,
"You will never believe
with what excitement he came
home and gave us that news."
-[ Laughing ]
She said,
"Please tell me it's true..."
[ Laughter ]
"...because he is so excited."
Yeah, they are looking forward
to this movie very much.
This is entirely suitable
for them
and, in fact, for all children.
'Cause it's a fun movie,
but it has an underlying,
quite serious theme
about being different and how
you want to celebrate that.
-Well, that's fantastic.
And it really is always just
such a joy to have you here.
Please come back anytime.
Thank you so much.
-I would love to.
-Patrick Stewart, everybody!